يعني حامل فستان عروس باي ذنب اذا تحولت
حياتها الى جحيم بلغم حوثي سؤال لم تمحي
السنوات من ذاكره دليل الشابه التي اسعفت
هي تنزف يوم عرسها الى الطوارئ المشفى عوض
ان تزفى الى عريسها فعلى بعد عشره
كيلومترات من منزلها في منطقه الشق بجنوبي
تعز تقف اليوم دليل بقدمين الصناعيين
لتشكو تاره من مراره النزوح ومعانتها
وتاره اخرى تشكو ماساه ذلك اليوم الذي
تحولت فيه فرحه عمرها الى اعاقه والم لا
يفارقنها منذ خمس سنوات
مانيش قادر ارجع بلادي
يعني اداني معقده من البلاد من الامه حصل
لي هذا شوف انه كانت تزفني عروسه اخر
زفوني للمستشفى زوجه تخلى عني لما حصل لي
هذا ابات الناس رقود اقدر
اقدر
ابنتي وصبر قلبي قلتوه قاهي بتعز ولا
تروحي باقي الحوتي
لست هنا للاعاقه ولا لوضع معشي بدا اكثر
تعقيدا فالشبه دليلا نازحه دون قدمين
تكافح من اجل الحصول على عشره الاف ريال
في اليوم تسد بها رمق اسرتها فالظروف
المعيشيه الصعبه والتزاماتها الاسريه
دفعتها للعمل رغم الاعاقه عملت البسطاء
النقطه الرابعه تقول المستشفى يعني
نسرع انفسنا بمصر في يوميه يعني نشقي على
اداره بيوت ولا على يعني على بطوننا ولا
على علاقات بهذا الحال يعيش المئات من
ضحايا الالغام في اليمن وتزداد اعدادهم كل
يوم فخلال فبراير الماضي ارتفع عدد ضحايا
الالغام الحوثيه الى 30% عما كان عليه في
السابق اذ اشارت احصائيه لمركز التعامل مع
الالغام الا ان اكثر من 1200 شخص في تع ز
سقطوا بين قتيلا وجريح بالالغام الحوثيه
من بينهم 220 امراه معضمهن يعشنا ماساه
الاعاقه حال هذه المراه اليمنيه اذا
يجسدوا واقع الحال لمئات المعاقين في
المدينه الذين دفعتهم الحرب الى الانخراط
في سوق العمل لاعاله اسرهم هل سعيد
العربيه تعز